- [Voiceover] "Kaylee wants
to do well in her classes,
"so she is budgeting her
time carefully to decide the
"number of classes, c,
she will take this year.
"For each class that she takes,
"she expects to spend two and a half hours
"each week working on homework.
"She expects to spend an
additional six and a half
"hours each week completing
the assigned reading
"for all of her classes together.
"If Kaylee has 19 hours
available each week
"to complete homework and
reading for her classes,
"which equation best
models the situation?"
Alright, so she has a total
of 19 hours available.
She has 19 hours available,
and she needs to...
She has 19 hours available each week
to complete homework.
To complete homework and
reading for her classes.
So how much time is it going to take her
to complete the homework?
Well it says that she expects
to spend two and a half
hours each week working on homework,
well actually I should say over here,
for each class that she
takes she expects to spend
two and a half hours each
week working on homework.
Let me underline that.
For each class that she takes
she expects to spend two
and a half hours each week
working on homework.
So it's going to be two and a half,
two and a half hours each week per class.
Now how many classes is she taking?
Well she's gonna take c classes.
She's gonna take c classes,
so the total amount that
she spends on homework.
So the amount that she spends on homework
is going to be two and a half times c.
I'll put it in parenthesis
just to make it clear
what I'm doing here, so
it's gonna be two and a half
times c is the amount
she spends on homework.
And how much is she
gonna spend on reading?
Well, it says over...
Says over here she expects
to spend an additional
six and a half hours each week,
completing the assigned
reading for all of her
classes together.
So this sentence says it
doesn't matter how many
classes she takes, she's
gonna spend six and a half
hours reading.
So, it's not dependent on the number
of classes she takes.
So this is the amount of time
she's just gonna spend reading.
And so the amount she spends on homework
plus the amount she spends on reading
need to add up to 19 hours.
So which of these choices are what I just
wrote over here?
So let's see, they have
the 19 on the other side.
Let's see, they have two and one half c
minus six and half.
No that's not this right over here.
Two and one half c plus six and a half.
Yep, that's what we have over here
is equal to 19.
Yep, that's this choice.
The only difference between this and what
I wrote is they just swapped the two sides
of the equality, which you can always do.
These other choices let's see.
Six and a half times c.
Well this would imply
they're just spending
six and a half hours per
class so that's not right.
And then this is also
six and a half times c,
so that's not gonna work out either.